when do you go at red and stopped at
green when you're eating of watermelon
ever wondered why traffic lights are
colored the way they are you may
probably say that red represents danger
Green is for safety and who cares for
yellow what could be the real reason
let's find out let's say we were to
select the colors for traffic signals
what factors should we keep in mind our
main focus should be the high visibility
of colors as this is extremely important
for the drivers it could be for a clear
view from a distance or for visibility
during extreme weather conditions in
such scenarios the most important signal
for us to be visible is stop so which
color should we choose first ah here's a
spectrum chart of visible light which
colors are most visible to you here
you'd probably say the ones in the
middle right the human eye is most
sensitive to green color followed by
yellow and blue so Green should be our
stop signal right not so fast we also
have to take the background into
consideration here during the day the
colors exhibited by our surroundings are
mostly green yellow and blue so green
would not contrast well with the
background red is the color that
contrasts best with these colors also
there is another factor that comes into
play here when light travels a certain
distance it gets scattered and we see a
blurred image out of all the colors red
scatters the least and violet the most
so red becomes a suitable choice for
this stop signal now what about the
other two signal lights
these are required when we are close
enough to the traffic signal and hence
the above-mentioned factors don't matter
much so we can use any two of green
yellow or blue for the goal and caution
signal historically
along with the red these two colors were
selected and implemented by the
railroads in the earlier 20th century
and afterwards the same scheme was
transferred first traffic signals you
might also be surprised to find out that
the middle color isn't yellow but it's
amber which is a mix of yellow and
orange so this kind of explains the
probable reason for choosing these
colors but is it always these three
colors did you note that there are
countries which have chosen blue over
green as their go signal why don't you
try and find the names of these
countries and tell us in the comment
section hold on we based our answer on
how visible different colors are to us
but why is one color more visible to us
than the other what do you think well it
depends majorly
on our eyes why the components of our
eyes are similar to that of a camera
we know that depending on its hardware
and software the image we see differs
from camera to camera similarly how we
see things in real life differs from
person to person
for instance one person may see a site
like this while a red and green
colorblind person will perceive the same
site like this so the different
components present in our eyes determine
the way we see things to know more about
the components of eyes visit the link in
the description below here we just
climbed the first step of the curiosity
ladder with you now the cue box is open
for you to explore do share your
thoughts in the comment section and if
you learned something new today do
share this video with your friends and
family